hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir ich habe euch bei
instagram gesagt dass ihr mir privat per
direct message ihre handynummer zu
schicken sollte und dann werde ich heute
zuschauer anrufen das habt ihr glaube
ich auch schon im titel gelesen
natürlich wenn ich die leute gleich
anrufen werde werde ich auch ein
bisschen mit denen reden und so aber ich
habe erst mal eine allgemeine frage an
jeden den ich anrufen werde und zwar
kennt ihr das wahrscheinlich wenn man
irgendwie 0 durch drei teil erhält man
immer 0 mit dem taschenrechner wenn man
allerdings 3 durch 0 teilt ist das nicht
möglich da steht dann im taschenrechner
sowas wie nicht definiert war oder eher
oder irgendwie so man kann das aber ganz
gut vergleichen mit falls ihr euch das
nicht erklären konnte noch immer nicht
durch 0 teilen kann
mit plätzchen also wenn du keine kekse
mehr da sind kann können die die kekse
die nicht da sind auch nicht geteilt
werden
ist ja auch egal auf jeden fall kann man
nicht durch 0 teilen und jetzt wenn ich
mal die leute ja anrufen werde die
fragen ob sie das überhaupt wissen also
ich hätte jetzt wie kluge eigentlich
seid
[Musik]
2000 jahre später ja du kannst dir
wissen du ich habe eine ganz kurze frage
an dich weißt du warst drei geteilt
durch 0 ist ja genau das erste miete
jetzt nicht hingekriegt aber mal schauen
ob die nächste person ist hinkriegen
wird
hallo hier ist luca wie geht es dir
heute gehe ja auch blendend ich habe
eine ganz kurze frage an dich weißt du
was drei geteilt durch 0 ist jetzt
gerade zwei telefone aneinander
also ich finde er hat jetzt auch nicht
wirklich hingekriegt weil sie halt
einfach dumm ist wie sie selbst gesagt
aber mal schauen ob die nächste person
es erraten kann
[Musik]
die hat mir die nummer vor einer minute
geschickt und dann einfach direkt
mailbox aber okay
ihr gespräch mega zähle ich das sage ich
einige bührer durch tristan und alle
sind nicht erreichbar
[Musik]
wollt ihr mich verarschen
hallo hier ist luca manca hey hey ich
hab mir ganz kurze frage an dich und
zwar kannst du mir sagen was drei
geteilt durch 0 ist wurde schon oder
nein das ist falsch mit euch hallo hier
ist luca wege durch haben eine ganz
kurze frage an dich kannst du mir sagen
was drei geteilt durch 0 ist durch den
bürgern seinen kopf retten soll
hallo hallo wie gehts ja mega gut geht's
mir hey du ich habe eine ganz große
frage an dich kannst du mir beantworten
was drei geteilt durch 0 ist irgendwie
denkt jeder das dreigeteilte ich 00 ist
ich habe freunde seid ihr da so
vielleicht regelt er jetzt die nächste
person das ganze hier für euch hallo
jeder begriffen du ich habe aber eine
ganz kurze frage an wen ich kannst du
mir beantworten was drei geteilt durch 0
ist gut mein fehler nein du hast mir das
paket geschickt mit dem konfetti alter
weg der jetzt in einem tempel hilfen für
diese person konnte jetzt auch nicht so
richtig rausreißen ich meine sie gar
kein auto aber freunde wir rufen sie
doch eine person doch mal schauen ob
diese person weiß was dreigeteilt dich
null ist
hallo hier ist das doch nicht wahr
hallo hier ist im bebop hey hier ist
luca wie geht's dir ich habe das gelände
nummer zugestellt zugesendet und darf
sich beruft sich malaga kann gar kein
problem
du ich habe aber eine ganz kurze frage
an dich kannst du mir beantworten was
drei geteilt durch 0 ist wahrscheinlich
sind deine eltern nichts zu finden
ok freude carola hat jetzt auch nicht
hingekriegt das ganze hier richtig zu
beantworten ich habe jetzt insgesamt
gegen die so 15 leute angerufen niemand
war hat die frage 3 durch 0 richtig
beantwortet das war bei mir damals das
einzige was so richtig im abi hängen
geblieben ist dass man nicht durch
nutzer 0 teilen kann dass das nicht null
ist und freunde jetzt alle durch die
küche seien einfach alles passen wenn
euch das ganze allerdings gefallen hat
dass ich angerufen hat und die das
eventuell nochmal haben wollte oder
falls sie irgendwelche prank zwist und
dann falls sie irgendwie wollte dass ich
jetzt noch mal ein anderen vormacht oder
keine ahnung was hätte er denn die
kommentare last ein like da und jetzt
kommt das auto oder das was ihr ziel vom
bio das was jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier in einen kanal
abonnieren oder
und meinen job ausschenken jetzt findet
ihr zwei andere videos und managen
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]